hey guys it's des the powder take care
and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and is
our review of the liam neeson starring
non-stop the greatest action hero of all
time taking on a plane kicked out of
playing yeah i have to say i'm surprised
i actually like the movie it's good i
miss lehman she's doing this thing guys
like 60-some years he's still doing this
thing he's he's believable as you know
he just bleed a badass he's a badass he
is I mean it's Liam Neeson yeah why GaN
Jin I mean I I thought it was fun I mean
silly yes silly but it's like a
throwback to the 90s action thrillers
and actually this movie is more of a
thriller than is action movie yeah the
trailers make you think it's gonna be
like a non-stop action and their art
there is action but it is it's more like
but kind of a whodunit in the little
ways just so we won't spoil anything
here you know it's a mystery and it slow
to develop but not slow in a boring way
it's just you though yes attention yeah
you just gotta if you buy into like the
silliness of right the primacy yeah then
you'll enjoy it the director his name is
John Colette sir I but I don't know I
guess he had worked previously with Liam
Neeson on that movie unknown we also
look like a taken call right yeah yeah
he uh Lisa's just become this action
star you know I mean it it's good and
bad at me and just got to you know get
dark on us all of a sudden by me after
his wife passed you know he just kind of
focused on work it was a great interview
with him on 60 minutes with Anderson
Cooper recently last week it's awesome
interview and he just dove into his work
he's been working non-stop but he's
developed himself into a really good
action star which is weird like all
these guys now Kevin Costner were three
days to kill or getting these action
movies late in their careers as opposed
to the Arnold's in the Sylvester
Stallone's and the doleful London's
there in there you know younger years
it's like it's cool to be old and be an
action star at the same time well i like
this movie a lot more than three days to
kill i saw 3d okay hey i was to say what
wasn't a big fan of that movie but
non-stop was was this video and yeah
seeing Liam Neeson also he buys into the
role right so we buy into his role and
the story also he's supported by you
really good cast yeah like you know
usually movies like this don't have okay
maybe they'll get the big star hmm but
then they won't get like someone as big
as Julianne Moore to play basically the
no second lead role in it very good Lady
Mary Crawley yeah Downton Abbey as well
dockery dockery uh Lupita of course you
just got an Oscar for 12 years a slave
has a small role but she's good it's a
good I mean this is what the old like
90s movies used to do like let's think
let's link on air he's cheesy like you
know a bunch of convicts in a play but
they put like John mouth always like
Academy award-winning actors like John
Hughes that's just it is stacked the
deck with great actors and it works and
they usually they don't really do it
anymore i think i think maybe these
movies are too big of a gamble do you
thing is that why they don't do them
anymore probably and I think a lot of
times you know egos involved they're
like oh I don't get to be the hero or
the star I don't want to be in that you
know right so yeah I remind me of like
executive decision passenger 57 open
arrow it looks like yeah all those just
cheat but they were good like they were
they were like plan Air Force One yeah I
mean justjust good action movies and you
know thrillers that's what this was I
was happy to see it definitely
definitely not recommended yeah I
recommend it as well I think it's fun as
long as you you don't take it too
seriously because I harped on it because
I look I just watched a lot of movies
right and I saw this non-stop trailer
every single time out of movies like
every any movie I saw other than maybe
like lego movie or something kind of
burned out on the trailer yeah and also
I just honestly I didn't think the
trailer looked very good yeah I thought
it looked really cheesy and so I was
expecting a cheesy movie in and while it
kind of was cheesy was cheesy in a good
way yeah yeah I mean it's just it's just
what you want from an action movie that
we saw a lot of in the 90s you don't see
too much anymore and it's just I'm I'm
glad that I'm glad they made you know no
superhero is just a dude with a gun in a
problem on a plane it's not snakes on a
plane that you know a problem more
sophisticated problem on a plane and
he's got to deal with it you know at
35,000 feet knows it was a great player
and it's it's like I said it's much more
of a thriller yeah than in action
you so what are your over thoughts in
grades both odds of Grey's I'm gonna
give this a b-plus I loved it you know
it's a great action movie is fun
definitely one mine seen again definite
recommendation I'd seen the theater I
mean you wait so comes home but I mean I
wouldn't i would say go seat in the
theater it's enjoyable evening since
she's doing this thing yeah I mean it's
enjoyable action thriller I'd say you
know you don't have to see in no no but
if you're looking for a good time you
get you know yeah you just want to be
entertained it's it's a nice two hours
I'm gonna give it a be i am not sure how
much i have to watch it again obviously
to see how much replayability this has
like rewatch ability through it this
marissa this movie has maybe i'll watch
it in and go like oh man this is
actually fun even the second time
because like taking is a movie that I
can watch multiple times right right and
maybe this will be one too yeah I'll see
let's see alright guys so you can post
your comments below on the website think
hero.com or on our youtube channel think
hero pro and make sure to subscribe to
that and let us know what you think of
this movie if you saw it you also go and
check us out on twitter if you want come
chat with us about any other your
favorite action movies from the 90s or
any action movies lately that you've
seen you expendables i guess is the new
big one of course you can find us at
think hero i'm at griffin de and we also
have a Facebook page that's facebook.com
slash think hero fans
you